大家好,我是學長,歡迎來到咖啡沖組攻略
那學長的頻道每週四都會更新一些金民咖啡的知識以及開箱
所以如果各位對金民咖啡有興趣的話呢
歡迎按下訂閱以及小鈴鐺
就可以收到每週的推播囉
那我們今天非常開心的來到了全台北市最難預約的咖啡店
來到雀
那我們歡迎主理人今晚
哈囉大家好,學長好
有到雀難預約嗎?會不會太誇張
對啊,其實之前真的很難預約啦
最近如果各位有想要來雀來喝喝看的話呢
每個月15號
準時上FB
稍微看一下那個
對準時其實就有啦
對你那個超級長的規則
先把它看完
超級長
5000字的規則
模式不一樣
預約制
我們還有很多要尊重的方式
那我們非常開心
今天請到今晚來跟大家聊聊
什麼叫做充足的好球袋
那你不同的豆子的情況之下
不同的充足好咖啡
以及如何在新芒上面應用
OK那我們廢話不多說
今晚來跟大家講一下
什麼叫做你心目中的好球帶
其實我覺得好球帶的定義啊
你可以把它想像成就是我們在看棒球的時候
不是投手在投球的時候都會有一個正方形的方框
就怎麼樣盡可能就是我一投
他就是進去那中間
那我覺得我就直接告訴你們一個捷徑好了
這個捷徑就是
等一下我們在討論呢
他跟四六法則他一定會有關係
然後我也直接告訴你們
這個所謂的好球帶他會很容易落在
1分50秒到2分10秒
20秒這個充足時間
你可以把它想像泡茶一樣
就是你泡的不夠多
那它的茶會出來
泡太久它會茶色
那這個4-6把針
你還可以去做一個
有時間可以做一個實驗
你可以用20克的咖啡豆
然後用300的熱水
然後你可以準備5個杯子
然後每個杯子就用這個濾杯
然後你就例如說
就60ml為一杯
然後你去喝喝看
它每個滴出來它底下的液體會是怎麼樣的味道
所以會有五杯
對會有五杯
所以剛剛講到我們四六八整
也是如果300mol的40%就是120
也就是前面兩杯
你前面兩杯你喝喝看
是大多的風味都已經在這邊了
那後面的三杯它其實就是濃淡度
它會開始慢慢的漸落
然後會開始轉一些甜度跟木質掉性的東西
那如果就是在沖煮的時候會碰到一些比較困難的
像常常碰到的時候
欸 潛焙好難充 極潛焙好難充
易技好難充 硬度高的怎麼辦
到底什麼時候要節流 什麼時候要不要流完
我告訴你 你只要有這個框架之後
你只要看到時間到了 節掉它 一定好喝
就是以這個框架 時間為核心框架
時間為核心框架 我們不敢說它百分之百
因為畢竟我們不是在比賽
可是我們要怎麼樣盡可能充出來的都很容易滿意
然後不挑綠杯 就算今天我是用星馬
我用B60 我今天用Kono 什麼都可以用
每一把都要80分
對 都可以80分以上
對 然後而且不論就是你咖啡的
例如說國家也好
沖焙度
沖焙度也好 通用
對 所以等一下我們就可以沖煮像這樣的沖煮方式
然後可以看看這樣子多段式注水的做法
那為什麼它可以成為一個所謂的好球蛋
OK 好 那我們就邊沖邊聊
我自己在沖煮的時候
我還是會習慣先進濕濾紙
那進濕濾紙我自己覺得有一個好處
就是一方面是讓它的濾杯可以先保溫
然後再來是我覺得它在做轉換的時候
它比較不會有一部分前面的咖啡被濾紙吸附掉
對 那我覺得這是我自己會喜歡做的一個優點
所以進濕完的時候
我們基本上我們大多的咖啡我們都可以用92度去沖對 那怎麼樣去方便它的溫度什麼時候要高什麼時候要低越淺焙溫度可以越高
可是我覺得這個上限值不要超過94度
因為超過94度的話
如果你沒掌握好很容易反苦
或是太尖
那相反的如果你尖是焙度越中焙
越中深焙
你溫度可以慢慢的往下降
那所以它其實簡單的架構邏輯就是
焙度越高溫度越低
相反的就是焙度越低溫度越高
然後我現在準備先磨豆
用15克的豆嗎
對我現在用15克的豆
這支是什麼豆
這支是等一下我們會來講解的一支情日
配方豆
等一下會講解一支情日
然後像磨開的時候
教大家一個小配布
就是如果今天我們不是買完豆很多就是會告訴你要不要養豆漆要不要怎麼樣
可是如果你今天迫不及待想要喝這隻豆子的時候
如果還沒到養豆漆那該怎麼做
你就可以一直去搖晃它
對搖晃它讓它有二氧化碳的去排放
那你等一下再沖煮它的時候你就會覺得味道比較順暢
那怎樣去判斷它有沒有搖完
就是你一開始在聞的時候會有一點點像烘焙啊堅果掉性
然後你這樣子搖啊搖或者是你拿一個攪拌池去搖一搖
你會開始聞到一些甜甜的水果味道
那代表它其實已經可以進行兩樣的充足了
就排氣排正常了
對
就罩位會掉了
對 罩位會掉
對 然後你就可以像先這樣子搖一搖
然後就可以倒到你的濾杯裡面去了
因為這是艷陽剛開始
剛磨出來的時候明顯沒有這麼艷麗的味道
然後我自己在做的時候我會喜歡用搖晃的
就是倒進去之後我喜歡搖晃它
我不喜歡拍它
因為拍它的話常常會有個狀態叫就是
你的細粉會一直堆積在底下
所以我基本上我只會用搖晃的
那我的做法會跟有些人有一點點不太一樣
是我喜歡在中間戳動
對我會喜歡從中間這樣子像是
把它畫成一個像漏斗的一個形狀
因為你可以想像的是
如果你今天平鋪因為它是錐形的
那它中間的粉塵就會比較厚
也就是說你在做前面悶震的時候
你中間給水要再給久一點點
它才會比較容易透進去
可是如果是像這樣子
它呈現一個你打開來
它會呈現一個V字型的粉塵
所以你在浸濕的時候
你就可以比較容易均直的在做浸泡
就不用特別關注中間了啦
內外圈的粉厚差不多
那我們第一次注水的話
我們會以粉的兩倍
就是大概30到40
不用太講久
就是超過也沒關係
放過自己
就是不要太苛責
大概兩倍左右啦
兩倍左右啦
多寡沒關係
然後就一樣中間注水丸
然後開始往外繞
然後往內
欸!36
然後我們這個時候就可以看他的排氣狀況
那有些人他們會問我們說
那到底怎樣去判斷他的排氣狀況好還是不好
基本上大多數都會落在20秒到30秒之間
或者是例如說你可以看他有沒有繼續膨
那像這樣的狀況下是他已經沒有繼續膨了
我們沒有繼續蓬了 我們就可以進行駐水
那我會先在中間駐水停留久一點點
然後開始往外繞
然後往外繞之後 往另一繞
然後到100
所以是30到100
這一段大概70
然後等一下下一段的時候
我們會是100到150
然後我們會 等一下再駐的時候
你會發現我們不會超過這個所謂的粉牆高度
對
然後這個時候幫我小繞圓就好這一段再來正中間的位置所以烤150它剛好到了它的粉塵的邊界
它就結束了
這個主要的目的是因為不要讓細粉再往下回流
就不要推到你的粉牆了
那它的順暢度它就會更好
然後所以等一下就會到它一樣下降的高度的時候
我們再進行下一次的入水
就會150到200
然後就一樣小水柱
然後小繞圓就好了
然後就一樣200它就會回到我剛剛的粉牆的位置
那等一下它到了一樣快一半的時候
我們這一柱會比較特別一點
就只有中間柱水就好了
那我們就是主要讓它下面底層的細粉再打通
讓它可以更順暢
就不繞圈了喔
對
水稍微大一點點
然後這時候它就會進行到所有的充足時間
我剛剛講了大多我們會希望是1分50秒到2分10秒
那可是如果像比較淺焙或是它風味比較特殊
我可以接受到20秒
盡量還是不要超過2分20秒
那如果它還沒有留完這個時候怎麼做呢
你就直接抽掉它吧
如果你會怕它味道會怎麼樣
你可以試試看
例如說好我找一個比較乾淨的容器
那你等一下喝喝看滴下來的這些東西它剩什麼
那你就可以思考的是這些東西會是你要的嗎
如果這個東西它已經不會是你要的
那其實不要它也沒有關係
對就是捨棄掉
對就捨棄掉直接捨棄掉
所以其實像我這一把沖的是2分18秒
對
它就沖住完了
對學長喝喝看
好
OK
情日
所以這個邏輯其實蠻簡單
30 悶蒸完到100 150 200
然後到225嘛
對 所以其實很好記
我其實已經把這套設計的它很好記之外
就是像剛剛講的
它每次的斷水
可是它又不會再讓你的粉牆破壞掉
對 所以才會有這樣子的一個斷水方式
這個設計其實整體萃取的狀態還是很均勻的
因為你每一次都有吃到你的粉牆
也不會犧牲到一些豆子
然後你整體喝起來確實
你說好球帶我非常可以理解
因為應該是大部分人都滿喜歡的味道
然後也不會有明顯的瑕疵
因為你的時間控制也是滿準的
對 然後手法也沒有特別難
對 然後其實像這個手法的話
它有一個小訣竅就是
如果你今天像剛剛我們現在喝到這個豆子
如果你希望它酸質再更高一點
那例如說像前面的悶蒸
例如說我剛剛講的
就是前面的悶蒸的這一段
跟到100的這一段
你可以比例稍微交換一下
例如說你悶蒸給水可以多一點
然後後面你再一樣補到100
然後你就會發現你的酸質會提升
所以其實如果你想要再酸一點的話
其實你這兩個只要稍微的比例調換一下
可是一樣總在100
對對對
也可以
所以其實你只要調整這個部分
後面都不用調
你就可以很容易瞄準好球帶
接下來就是溫度高跟低就好
例如說你覺得你想再更亮一點點
例如說我剛剛92度
我可以選93度
或者是再不夠亮就94度
可是我覺得92度假設它已經夠酸了
我覺得想要再更甜一點那就往下降
所以其實這個邏輯已經很簡單
然後通用所有的咖啡
不管是處理方式啊
或者是譬如說產區啊
或者是像我剛剛講的不管是液劑這種是機潛培通用
然後不挑濾杯
這個框架大家應該都明白啦
至於溫度啊或者說第一段的門擠小調整
大家可以自己嘗試剛剛那個沖法呢Sean覺得其實非常值得大家來參考的所以難度也不高所以如果各位在家裡面的話呢平常碰到新的豆子不是很明白齁
不知道怎麼沖的話可以參考一下今晚的沖法
真的蠻不錯的
OK 那我們剛剛沖的那支咖啡是什麼豆子
我們剛剛沖的那杯叫情日
嗯
然後情日其實是我這邊的一個交織配方
那為什麼會有交織這兩個字
是因為它對於我來說就有點像是
把所有的好跟不好去穿拆在一起
就是每隻豆子都一定套到它的優點跟缺點
那這次的這隻配方
它其實裡面有五隻豆子
它有哥倫比亞就是我們持耳熟能香的豔夏華麗
然後它有哥斯大儀家的一隻叫死裡桃花
它也是艷陽的
然後有兩隻艷陽
跟就是大家也很熟悉的哥斯大儀家貝多芬
對這種很特殊的豆子
這是富達甘命處理
它是酵素隨行
然後一隻 依索比亞四八女王
它是一隻賽豆
然後裡面還有一隻瓜地馬拉的特蘭湖水洗
那為什麼會這樣子去做比例呢
那其實像大家其實如果這樣聽到的話會知道
其實如果對燕蕭花麗有那個概念
是知道它的味道很重
所以其實燕蕭花麗其實在這裡面的佔比其實是最低的
因為用我們以前比較少
我們會把它拿燕養做配方豆
因為它的味道很重
對 因為燕養對於我來說
我自己會覺得耐喝跟好喝是兩回事
對這很麻煩
因為燕養就不太耐喝
對
因為我覺得你可以把它想像成花果茶跟茶
各有愛好者
我不會說哪個好哪個不對
就是大家都有自己的喜好
我今天可能忽然想喝個花果茶
我今天燕養我也覺得很開心
我今天想喝個好茶
那我今天就不會想要選
喝水洗
對對對
所以我覺得剛好
我今天會做這個配方
也是希望去彌補
這樣豔養他很常容易尾韻會空掉的問題
跟他雖然前面很香 可是他的body體質不夠好
那怎麼樣去藉由其他豆子去補強他
那像這樣的概念
其實這次咖啡原本是做給我們情日早餐部的一個完全預約制咖啡館
那那時候對我來說他是一個
我的想像畫面是他應該是要很甜美
然後對 就是很美好的早餐
因為大家早上起來通常心情都不會太好
可是你如果有一個很好喝的咖啡
香香的甜美的
那是帶你心情會更好
所以那時候就先有了這個畫面
我才開始去找豆子
對
然後我剛剛有提到沖煮
我這邊想要再幫大家補充一下下
很多人會問我說粗細度該磨多少
那也就是說如果剛剛你的
這樣子的沖煮方式
如果你一直進不到這個框架
如果你今天一分半就一直就沖煮完了
那麻煩你幫我磨細一點點
那假設你怎麼樣子沖
你可能都會超過2分30秒
那你幫我磨粗一點點
你就可以解決掉這個問題
以時間回推啦
對對 以時間回推
你就不用擔心說你今天用什麼樣的磨豆機
你還要問我要怎麼磨豆機
對
很煩
對 這樣子不快
對
然後這一支
琴琴的話是我們的限定配方
所以它結束就是會結束了
對
其實蠻棒的
因為學長最近喝了蠻多
幾個朋友他們都是用艷陽來做配方
我覺得是事實上比
純和艷陽來的有意思啦
因為確實好喝跟耐喝
這個會打架
有些燕養處理的比較俗燕一點
會受不了
這個配方喝起來真的覺得蠻平衡的
香氣跟氣質都蠻不錯的
OK 那今天非常開心
非常感謝今晚跟大家分享這個好球袋
以及他的這支新的豆子
那如果各位有什麼任何問題的話
歡迎在底下留言囉
那我們下次見 掰掰
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目